is it a good idea is this going to
transform people's lives in these areas
well I mean if I take 15 pound of you
and then give you two pound 80 is that
going to transform your life
these guys they've found 2.8 billion
pounds to give to local councils in the
last three years they're given 700
billion pounds to the rich I know you
understand now you've met 50 times as
much listen is it leveling up if I give
a poor person two pound 80 and I give a
rich person 250 pounds no sorry 700
pounds 250 times as much listen
this government has presided over the
largest and fastest ever increased
inequality in the history of the country
and the most orwellian thing you've ever
heard they call that leveling up
what do you say I think in this case
we're talking about relatively trivial
amounts of money for projects that often
ought to be financed by the private
sector I think this really underscores
the problem with things like the
leveling up fund which is that they
create anomalies and then the case is
always made for more the government
comes Under Pressure to spend more and
we need to remember that the